oh hi there Hank it's Friday October
24th and this is the bathroom they gave
me at this hotel Shawn I couldn't bring
myself to actually put it on naked
because I don't know what the previous
tenants did in it Hank I've got like
four minutes to record today's video
blog so it's all gonna have to be in one
take which as you know from having seen
the footage that I don't put into
vlogbrothers videos means that today's
video is gonna suck sorry but I just
wanted to say a couple things number one
you are getting punished but I'm going
to punish you by making you do something
that you already should have done you
once agreed to go to the Sex in the City
movie dressed as Carrie Bradshaw now
you've got to do it even though it's not
in theaters so you'll have to do it at
your house but whatever seeing you
dressed as Carrie Bradshaw will still be
funny also think I want to say thanks to
you into all the nerdfighters who made
it possible for Paper Towns to premiere
at number 5 on the New York Times best
seller list next week I mean I was
surprised last December when
nerdfighters proved that they could take
over YouTube but I didn't think we could
take over the New York Times bestseller
list so thanks to everyone who bought
Paper Towns and I hope you like it
hold on I got to recreate the thing on
the side bar also Hank the New York
Times bestseller list is not the only
good thing that's happened to Paper
Towns in the last 48 hours in what is
surely the best-kept secret in the
history of nerdfighteria Hank I can now
officially tell you and everyone that
the movie rights the Paper Towns have
been optioned by mandate and mr. mud the
people who made that great movie Juno I
mean Hank the last time these people
made a movie it won a bunch of Oscars no
pressure or anything by the way it was
the producers at mr. Mudd who I said
best wishes to lo those many months ago
but it didn't make them hate me now they
want to make a movie best wishes for the
win Hank before I go I have to tell you
what happened in my second novel an
abundance of katherines was published on
the day it came out the Yeti and I went
to a bookstore and there were no copies
then I went home and we had some soup
and then we watched CSI and went to bed
the fact that this experience has been
so radically different that I got to
hang out with 200 made of awesome
nerdfighters last night well hundreds
more watching on blogtv I think it's the
nicest gift that I've ever been given
Hank I'm not gonna get cheesy on you I'm
not gonna say the l word but I hope you
understand that all of this would have
been impossible
without you so anyway Hank in solidarity
with you and your punishment and also to
express my gratitude to the nerdfighters
I have a question from nerdfighteria
what can I do for you you want me to eat
a blenderize - happy meal you want me to
send some money to Bangladesh you tell
me I owe you guys big time and I know I
can't pay you back but I'm gonna start
trying let me know what I can do for you
and comments Hank
nerdfighters thank you thank you thank
you for being awesome and as always best
wishes